all right we're here
keep pointing at me stop actually
Stamey's now stop the start start yeah
I'm not telling you started yeah I cook
some mom dinosaur wings yeah same as
buffalo wings but you can get chicken
drumsticks for us sometimes cheaper per
pound get them chicken drumsticks
there's more meat on them yeah they were
really good right fry him up tossed him
in tossed him into butter and hot sauce
yeah put some blue cheese dressing with
it
mix some blue cheese dressing into
coleslaw mix it was a [ __ ] like a
picnic but it was inside I'm gonna do it
again but I cuz I got some um I got some
General Tso's chicken sauce general
sales charge Errol so sauce made yeah
imagine taro some of that yeah magic you
know okay I like I got some tires out
there will do thighs next time yeah so
happy might that's my favorite all right
oh it's bone-in but you know I'm ready
to go I just all right oh okay well
that's like aren't you supposed to like
when you make paprikash like Hungarian
paprikash I'm supposed to use or am I
thinking of something else are you
supposed to use like thighs or chicken
on the bone or what guys and bone-in
yeah they like they like thighs with
legs they eat it with bone you know on
the bone but you know like that's
something you really could find commonly
in the United States yeah it's much
easier to do it
yeah paprikash lot of times that's some
[ __ ] up on a smorgasbord that was back
when your grandparents you know what I
mean that was your grandma's core you
know you've made it yeah yeah yeah
typically the u.s. they deboned it yeah
to make it easier yeah I mean and it's
good both ways it's good on mashed
potatoes and it's good on noodles the
American recipes tend to be wrong when I
had that that Hungarian paprika
made a big difference than it I just got
that at Publix yeah can't a big ol metal
can like rated they kind of hit it it
was like reneges yeah they use a lot
more in hungary and they they make it
hot that's that's like chili that's
their version
chili yeah they're kind of like their
version a curry it's similar I kind of
feel like every culture has a chili
slash karika yesh don't they pop Prakash
up and say like Michigan because I've
had it there - it was just creamy
it wasn't very spicy but yeah that's not
really authentic well yeah I can't those
are the older I get the less spicy food
I can eat right as most people as you're
most of you will finally find out
whether you know when you get a hold yes
stomach just 4 mils
another one I like pierogies because I
just ate so I'm not hungry
like just cheese pierogies cheese and
potato pierogies yeah we're always
talking about food yeah we gotta go for
a walk again sometime today before it
gets too late what time is it it's 4
o'clock yeah but yeah
it's a Sunday we're not really doing a
hell of a lot what yes we're just making
a boring video yeah we're just making a
boring boring what's going on Jenny no
I'm just saying well all I've been doing
today I put up the Matt name review so
finally everybody can see our video
Farah read our reviews of extraction and
blood-quantum and the dust Walker yeah
decimal dirt Walker dirt surfer we'll
see I don't think I think I only have
like one comment on on that review so
for my setup a few hours account yeah
but I've been doing that and then I was
working on artwork for my games website
like I said it's probably not gonna be
up until later this year but I'm trying
to like get and all the games aren't
done but I have so many games done that
I'm trying to like build a new website
so I'm making like all this little art
like for the you know and I'm trying to
figure out like how to organize the
website because but other than that it's
like not a lot going on what so we
watched one of the movies that I think
Joseph sent us Winchester yeah it looks
good it was actually pretty decent it
was like better than it because I
remember when it came out in the
theaters and
I remember I got kind of like man
reviews but it was actually pretty good
I like Helen Mirren anyway and it was
really good and I mean it went with and
we did a show about the Winchester
Mystery House where I you know I'm not
sure how true that [ __ ] is about how she
built the house like to confuse the
spirits yeah I got no theory because of
all the [ __ ] and actually but I did like
that they kind of expanded on that a
little bit in the movie by saying that
she was building all these crazy rooms
because she was building the rooms that
the people that haunted the house had
died in and it was like you could like
trap them and they're kind of so I liked
that you know that aspect of it because
it kind of made it more pulled together
like the narrative you know rather than
just some random hey she's just building
a house randomly I had another theory
about that house and somebody who works
for the Association that protects that
house so I can thank me for my theory
yeah because we didn't try to make her
sound like she was [ __ ] nuts or this
something with that that woman worked
there and all you know in all her
co-workers they they liked Miss
Winchester and they had a different
understanding of that house but I think
it was is that it was the Victorian era
she was a single widowed woman it wasn't
proper for them to really be going out
dating or anything
seances in spirit the spiritualism was
real popular that was considered to be
like real high-class and kind of like a
high tech oh yeah everybody there was a
super in vogue and having you know
having construction guys over at the
house 24 hours a day I mean she couldn't
travel I don't think there wasn't much a
single woman could do even if you had a
whole bunch of money basically what this
was was it was calling a bunch of young
worker men over to the house all the
time and like keep her company you keep
her company I think that's what it was
it's you know making sure that you know
making sure that she had cute guys
working on the damn house she look out
the window look down the hallway watch
him work and ask
they want any [ __ ] lemonade that's
what they want to cuz in there she was
in no hurry for any of this work to get
done and this was a conscious source I
haven't young men in the house that's
what I believe it was well and plus she
might have been like interested in
architecture and [ __ ] like that to
wanted to like try different [ __ ] house
like in different parties we constantly
asking her about decor and Casta
shopping she's shopping from home
basically instead of you know they'd
have the internet then you know the
people in women like to shop and but you
know she was rich enough to have the
wouldn't be shopping women were mesh and
she was rich enough she's rich enough to
shop at home and you know she'd be
looking all the cash she'd have salesmen
can't cater into her and women cater
into her and you know talking about
decor and that's that's what I believe
it was about yeah and I mean I like in
the movie that even though obviously
they had to make it a straight-up good
story because it was a horror story but
they initially um you know posited that
she was nuts because she was seeing all
this stuff and like the you know the
narrative thrust was you know the
psychiatrist was coming there
psychologist or whatever he was was
coming there to assess her because they
were thinking of taking her off the
board of Winchester repeating rifles but
then he he initially did think she was
nuts because she kept saying hey I'm
like seeing all these ghosts and they
like you know she's doing the automatic
writing and they're making her draw the
rooms and stuff but it turned out that
she was right so she wasn't crazy at all
no this is just in the fictional movie
yeah that's just a big night out ideas
don't get confused yeah that's two
completely different things I think it
was more about having young guys from
the in the house and being able to shop
from the house and being able to be kind
of catered to all the time so she was
wouldn't get lonely that's what I think
and it'd be really cool she's doing all
this spiritualism [ __ ] and she that's
what I think if I had that much money
and yech
I mean and you could just keep building
on a house like you pretty much had she
pretty much had endless fun we had
endless funds I mean I mean I think
that'd be kind of neat like dollars
because people go how could you do that
to your house how could you spend so
much money from her point of view she
was just she wasn't spending any money
she was just paying for entertainment it
didn't cost much and
she couldn't [ __ ] the house up because
she could just buy another house and
move away from it yeah she had nothing
to lose
yeah by doing that and the house was
still single in there today yeah go
visit it now yeah and she made a famous
house a tourist kind of thing and it had
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] in it and like a
funhouse it's like a funhouse
but she didn't live in those parts of
the house she was just adding stuff to a
house the eddorian the house it was big
enough that she had her own wing you
didn't have to go over there yeah you
know when workers weren't there she
could walk around it like it was a damn
fun house and [ __ ] trip out and talk
to talk about spirits although I don't
think I think maybe she did believe in
spiritualism but I don't think she was
having any paranormal experience yes and
a lot of people believe in spiritual
like I said it was very much a thing
yeah so I don't I don't think there was
anything wrong no I don't think I think
she's just having fun it's like you know
she's a rich woman having fun yeah think
about it and a lot of people that have
that much money they have eccentricities
because they can just they have the
money to like indulge their whims and I
don't think that is any weirder than
some of the other [ __ ] that rich people
have gotten up to in art in our day in
our day she just would have been just a
rich goth girl yeah yeah dude doing
weird [ __ ]
yeah probably would have thought of her
is that strange no obvious I mean I
don't think I don't think people thought
of her is that strange I don't I don't
remember any reports of anybody saying
that she was anything other than just
real Pleasant yeah I think everybody
that knew her yeah said she was just
cool yeah didn't know she was crazy or
anything like that I think it had it a
lot of it had to do I think with
flirting with guys what woman have need
yeah I mean well thank you for telling
me that have needs well she's got his
dinners working and they're working
inside the house okay you're working
inside the house and outside the house
and inside the house and she could
always say Oh sweetheart you look so
tired why don't you come sit here and
take this take a load off have have a
lemonade have some cookies have some
cookies
bring out the phonograph [ __ ] player
she wasn't in any [ __ ] hurry to get
that house done
she told people she wasn't in the area
to get it done so hey as long as she's
paying the people she gave all those
people like steady work yeah yeah and
and I'm sure they probably knew what was
up yeah they look good and a good
entertainer Lee dudes [ __ ] all sweaty
taking their shirts off you don't mind
if I take off the 40 you're mad [ __ ]
what she's offering him a raise a man if
[ __ ] father a [ __ ] basically the
[ __ ] father of bodybuilding you know
[ __ ] huge and Sandow right basically
had a whole [ __ ] career built upon
selling [ __ ] basically kind of like
semi nude selfies yeah that was the
[ __ ] that was that his empire was
built upon on nude selfies and two pound
dumbbells carrying a budget like back in
the old days they need to do before it
was acceptable to come out as gay for
example um I feel like there was a big
like underground not even an underground
trade but there was a trade in like
magazines and photos and stuff like that
of bodybuilders and you'd say oh I'm
just interested in male fitness and I
look like that yeah like that even
though that yeah but in Sandow's case
though you know there was he he had lots
of female admirers and evidently women
groups of women were going to these what
he would call like private showings
mm-hmm okay
for the females all the Chippendales
[ __ ] Chippendales
that's exactly what he's [ __ ] talking
about that private ladies only and you
know ladies only viewings you know
they're like look he's just some selfies
and [ __ ] yeah I was [ __ ] the
original strong man or one other
original strong man and now you know you
[ __ ] win the Olympia you get the sand
out trophy man sand out [ __ ] he was a
[ __ ] natty man he was all natural
talkin
just check him out you can see him
that's funny it's actually films of him
survived imposing do impose and routines
it's funny that you brought that up
because for some reason yesterday I was
thinking about that movie The Full Monty
yeah like the British steel workers that
write a work and like yeah there are
Chippendales think man I need to see
that movie again that movie was [ __ ]
hilarious yeah I gotta do a [ __ ] show
on Sandow and Sandow and like some of
the famous [ __ ] old strong men of the
1800s
[ __ ] Pandora no because you know we
did we did Houdini and those guys we yes
a long time ago did Houdini long and
those guys were similar it was a similar
kana gig and we did like a circus
sideshow one but we didn't really talk
about strongmen although much we just
kind of talked about like human oddities
see the thing the thing was strongmen
and guys like sent Sandow was the one
who really [ __ ] you didn't they had
all these Greek and Roman statues in
greco-roman art you know and it was
proven that these statutes really were
from that era but most people in that
day thought that that was all [ __ ]
that there was an idealized sculpture
that a human couldn't look like that
ants and eugen figured that no I think I
can get myself to look like he took all
the measurements off the statues to get
the proportions right yeah and then set
about to try to figure out how to look
like that he did it so he so part of it
part of what his challenge was is to
prove that those Greek and Roman statues
were based on real people and you really
could look like that yeah and really
what that mean means is is that the
Greeks and the Romans knew about
bodybuilding
that's [ __ ] that and they were doing
it without ikana anabolic steroids and
this was you know that's that's
high-technology yeah you have to
understand you gotta eat a lot of
protein and lifting weights and
progressive resistance which you know
that's not something you would just
stumble upon you know I mean you'd have
to think about that I guess and it would
probably be like a whole bunch of
people's different carry studies and
theories yes I could be in like a lot of
you know just kind of trying things and
seeing that it was part of the whole
[ __ ] industry
trial and error that it was part of the
whole industry of sports medicine the
Greeks and Romans had when it came to
like Olympic Games and gladiatorial ad8
or fights and gladiatorial combat and
and you know so and then even evidently
women weren't involved in this too the
Greeks had a class of women called porn
a where the word porn comes from and
they were professional erotic
entertainers that would come to parties
and big groups only rich people could
afford them evidently they did this to
porn eh yeah and it is to get a good
build on them so it's it's weird you
know I mean because lifting weights and
bodybuilding it's not natural behavior
no because it's you know most people
naturally take the easy path not the
harder path yeah oh this I can't take it
yeah I mean oh it hurts oh that hurts I
won't do that again that's what the most
people's reaction to that kind of [ __ ]
you know so you know I guess if you
didn't know what you were doing and you
didn't know if it would yield results or
not in those days you might think it
might kill you or that is something kind
of sega sadomasochists as he said a
masochistic but you won't get anything
from it
yeah pogies in here you don't poop she
was taking a nap but she was like oh I
hear knocking in there she busts in
later does the doors can like put her
ass in a camera again yeah yeah bit
about it that's all I wanted to say
alright so we'll wrap this up for Sunday
um you gonna say bye to the people pokey
no she's not gonna say no she doesn't
know where the cameras are all right uh
so you guys have a good rest of your
weekend and we will talk to you again
tomorrow